a turnout for the books a real moment in
history a record attendance for the
women's six nations with more than 58
000 people visiting the home of rugby
where today the ladies ruled the roost
and for fans hoping to see England lift
the Grand Slam after beating their
closest European Rivals the red roses
didn't disappoint
at half time it looked like a done deal
with England scoring five tries and
France failing to reply
but France came back strong for the
second half scoring three tries of Their
Own
but the red roses fought the French back
and added another to their Hall making
it the fifth successive Six Nations
victory for England
we've won you know with some fantastic
rugby but like Marley said you know four
four credits to France so they're
absolutely exceptional the character
they showed and the rugby they played
and you know we we opened the door we
invited them in and you know and they
came to the party big time this is this
is where the game needs to be and
another huge win for women's sports
inspiring fans of all ages
they made me sort of want to do it again
yeah because it's it's just so fun we've
never been able to please football rugby
when we were that age never happened no
we came to the men's Six Nations and
really wanted to come to today to see it
and the school level is just superb and
it's really great to show some excellent
role models for fertility and other
young girls growing up
a resort and a turnout that England can
be proud of
but the real Target is a full house in
two years time when England will compete
in the 2025 World Cup
Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News